so normally i get to talk to someone
about you know the current season and
now you know it's card season two but
you guys are also filming picard season
three right now so i get to ask this
question uh what can you tease about
picard season two and season three
well the quick answer is we can't tease
anything about picard season three
except that we're almost done shooting
it and it's gonna be
amazing um and you guys will love it but
i can't tell you anything else beyond
that about season three well we can tell
you one thing which is kind of big um
and it's always been this way uh season
three will be our
finish of star trek picard
it's always been planned that way and i
think the thing that's really cool about
that one you know is that our writers
and producers get to create a um
a a lovely send-off you know so that we
don't it's not like a surprise like
cliffhanger and we're done you'll never
see this again um we get to really um
finish uh telling a story and i think
you guys are gonna really dig it both
seasons season two and season three are
uh amazing adventures a rollercoaster
ride um we got easter eggs oh yeah we
got easter eggs all over it so that you
guys can like find some stuff and be
like wait a second i know what that's a
nod to uh so i think it's going to be um
a real pleasure and a fun adventure for
new and old fans
um have you guys actually read the
series finale script or are you still
we're shooting it
oh so you really know how it all ends oh
you feel like you you we really really
do really
right i i completely get it so i listen
i'm a huge star trek fan and everyone
who's gonna watch the interview star
trek fans what do you think actually
would surprise people to learn about the
making of picard that maybe they
wouldn't know outside of the cove at all
because you know obviously covet sucks
and shooting with that is a real
you know terrible
we're all 12 year old boys yes
absolutely basically that's probably
kind of a surprise to most people
yeah the conversation and and uh
yeah in the green in our little chairs
off off screen is very colorful
we are teenagers
was not expecting that answer yet i love
it um what do you think so obviously q
is a big part of season two and i would
imagine q carries over to season three
what do you think it is about the
character that is so popular with so
many of the fans oh well a good villain
is
loved forever right you know like
someone who's complex and
um powerful and omnipotent like he is i
mean it's it's hard to
how can you not want to sort of see what
else he could do and and have him come
back and john de lancie is just such a
wonderful actor that you know he's very
compelling to watch i think absolutely
yeah he's delicious on screen
for sure um i got to stop there i'm just
going to say sincerely congrats on the
first few episodes we can't wait to see
where it all goes
thank you so much